>>Laura: I'M LAURA INGRAHAM
AND THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE
FROM WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
LET'S START RIGHT OFF, BIDEN
GOES FULL SHARPTON THAT IS THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT ANGLE.
>> IT WAS HORRIBLE AS YOU SAW T
SEE PEOPLE TREATED LIKE THEY DID
, OR LIST RUNNING OVER PEOPLE
AND PEOPLE BEING STRAPPED, AND
HEIGHT OUTRAGEOUS, I PROMISE YO
THOSE PEOPLE WILL PAY.
THEY'RE WILL BE, THERE IS AN
INVESTIGATION UNDERWAY NOW AND
THERE WILL BE CONSEQUENCES.
>> SO MUCH FOR BIDEN PACK INTO
THE MIDDLE TO UNITE THE COUNTRY
AND SAVE HIS PRESIDENCY.
WE SUGGESTED THAT LAST NIGHT.
THE AMIABLE OLD MAN WHO RAN FOR
PRESIDENT WITH A PLEDGE TO BRIN
US ALL TOGETHER HAS DECIDED
MOVING HARD LEFT IS HIS ONLY
OPTION.
WE KNOW WHAT THE HARD LEFT
THINGS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHETHER IT'S COPS ON THE BEAT O
A DANGEROUS SUBURBAN AREA
GETTING OVERRUN BY CRIMINALS,
BORDER PATROL IN TEXAS TRYING T
DEFER COSTINGS.
WE'LL CRY RACISM WHENEVER THEY
BELIEVE IT HELPS THEM
POLITICALLY.
THE FACTS JUST DON'T MATTER.
JUST AS THEY DID WITH THAT CASE
THE LEFT IS SEIZING ON AN IMAGE
ONE IMAGE TO MAKE UNFOUNDED
DEFAMATORY CLAIMS.
IT'S INCREDIBLY STUPID, WHICH I
WHY KAMALA HARRIS WAS HAPPY TO
JOIN IN.
I WAS OUTRAGED BY IT, IT WAS
HORRIBLE, AND DEEPLY TROUBLING.
THERE HAS BEEN NOW AND
INVESTIGATION BEING CONDUCTED,
WHICH I FULLY SUPPORT AND THERE
NEEDS TO BE CONSEQUENCE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
HUMAN BEINGS SHOULD NOT BE
TREATED THAT WAY.
>> SHE'S TALKING ABOUT THE
PEOPLE ON HORSEBACK.
AND THEN SHE TALKS ABOUT
CONSEQUENCES AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THAT IS HILARIOUS COMING FROM A
ADMINISTRATION THAT STILL HASN'
FIRED ANYONE, NO ACCOUNTABILITY
THEREFORE 13 OF OUR TROOPS BEIN
SLAUGHTERED AT THE KABUL AIRPOR
OR AFTER THAT WATCHED
RETALIATORY DRONE STRIKE THAT
KILLED TEN, SEVEN INNOCENT KIDS
AND YOU KNOW WHAT'S HORRIBLE AN
DEEPLY TROUBLING BANHAM VICE
PRESIDENT?
IS THAT WE NOW HAVE BEEN A
MINISTRATION RUN BY PEOPLE WHO
HAVE NOTHING, BUT DISDAIN FROM
THE HARD-WORKING MEN AND WOMEN
WHO PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE
EVERY SINGLE DAY TO KEEP US SAFE
.
THIS IS DISGUSTING.
>> IT ALSO EVOKED IMAGES OF SOM
OF THE WORST MOMENTS OF OUR
HISTORY WHERE THAT KIND OF
BEHAVIOR HAS BEEN USED AGAINST
THE INDIGENOUS PEOPLE OF OUR
COUNTRY, HAS BEEN USED AGAINST
AFRICAN-AMERICANS DURING TIMES
OF SLAVERY.
>> THEY'RE IS THAT WE ARE
LAUGHED AGAIN.
IS SHE NOT AWARE OF THE FACT
THAT NATIVE AMERICANS RODE ON
HORSEBACK THEMSELVES IN HOSTILE
SITUATIONS OR DID SHE MISS THAT
PART OF HISTORY?
AGAIN, BIDEN AND HARRIS NEVER
SPEAK IN THIS MANNER IN THIS
VERY AGGRESSIVE TONE ABOUT CHINA
, WHICH IS ACTUALLY
COMMITTING GENOCIDE.
THEY NEVER SPEAK ABOUT ILLEGAL
ALIENS OR REFUGEES WHO,
UNSPEAKABLE CRIMES WITH SUCH
CONDEMNATORY TOMES.
IT'S NOT AN EXACT TORT TO SAY
THAT THE BUY NEW MINISTRATION
SPEAKS CHARITABLY ABOUT THE
TALIBAN THAN IT DOES U.S. LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
BY THE WAY, THEY CAN ALL STOP
PRETENDING TO CARE ABOUT THE
AMERICAN WORKING CLASS, THEY
DON'T EVEN WAIT FOR AN
INVESTIGATION, THEY JUST VIEW
POISONOUS RHETORIC ABOUT LAYING
BORDER PATROL AGENTS WHO ARE
OVERWHELMINGLY HISPANIC BY THE
WAY.
THEY ARE PAID ANNUALLY ONLY
FRACTION OF WHAT HUNTER POCKETS
FROM ONE LOUSY PAINTING.
YET BY MIMICKING AL SHARPTON
ANDRES, JOE AND KAMALA JUST MAK
THEMSELVES LOOK MORE PETTY AND
LESS SERIOUS.
IT'S ALL ONE BIG CHANGE OF
SUBJECT MOVE ON THEIR PARTS.
FROM THE IMAGES OF MIGRANT
SQUALOR IN DEL RIO TO THE IMAGE
OF SLAVE TRADER BORDER AGENTS O
HORSEBACK.
THE TRUTH IS, BIDEN IS TO BLAME
HIMSELF FOR BOTH IMAGES, WHICH
IS WHY HIS POLL NUMBERS ARE IN
FREEFALL.
HE IS VIOLATING NOT JUST HIS
UNITY PROMISE, BUT HIS ALL
FOLLOW THE SCIENCE PROMISE AS
WELL.
HIS CDC PANEL OVERWHELMINGLY
REJECTED RECOMMENDING VACCINE
BOOSTERS FOR ALL, BUT OLDER
AMERICANS, BUT JOE DOESN'T CARE.
TO GET MADE IT CLEAR ALL ALONG,
THE DECISION OF WHICH BOOSTER
SHOT TO GIVE WHEN TO START THEY
SHOT, AND HE WILL GET THEM IS
LEFT TO THE SCIENTISTS IN THE
DOCTOR SPIRIT THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED HERE.
WE BOUGHT ENOUGH BOOSTER SHOTS
AND STATES AND PHARMACIES,
DOCTORS OFFICES AND COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS HAVE BEEN
PREPARING TO GET BOOSTER SHOTS
AND ARMS FOR A WOW.
THE PANEL VOTED 16-TO THEY WERE
OVERRIDDEN.
FOR WHATEVER THEY WANTED.
IN OTHER WORDS, FAUCI AND PFIZE
ARE GOING TO GET.
THAT EXTENDS TO PRESSURING THE
ADULTS WHO DECLINED THE VACCINE
FOR WHATEVER REASON.
BIDEN THINKS HE CAN INSULT HIS
WAY TO POPULARITY.
>> THREE QUARTERS OF THE
ELIGIBLE HAVE GOTTEN AT LEAST
ONE SHOT.
ABOUT ONE QUARTER HAS NOT GOTTE
ANY AND THEY ARE CAUSING A LOT
OF DAMAGE.
THE VACCINATED OVERCOME OUR
HOSPITALS, OVERRUNNING INTENSIV
CARE UNIT SPIRIT CAN GET YOUR
CAUSING DAMAGE, AND FUNNY, HOW
YOU'RE NOT WORRIED ABOUT
MILLIONS OF MIGRANTS TAKING UP
HOSPITAL BEDS USING OUR
RESOURCES, WHICH THEY DO ALL TH
TIME.
MOST OF THEM ARE OBVIOUSLY NOT
VACCINATED MISTER PRESIDENT, AN
THERE BEING SHIPPED ALL OVER TH
UNITED STATES TO SEE THE REST O
THE COUNTRY WITH COVID.
SPEARMAN THE CONCERN ABOUT USIN
UP HOSPITAL RESOURCES.
BUT ABOUT THE CONCERN ABOUT
SOCIAL DISTANCING HERE?
WHO REALLY BELIEVES THAT ONLY 18
-20 PERCENT OF THESE MIGRANTS
ARE TESTING POSITIVE FOR COVID?
AT THIS POINT WE ARE LUCKY IF W
CAN FIND ANYONE WHO STILL WANTS
TO WORK IN BORDER PATROL GIVEN
THIS NIGHTMARISH SITUATION.
TODAY, THE LIES OFTEN COME SO
FAST FROM BIDEN THAT SOMETIMES
IT'S HARD TO KEEP UP AND I'M A
FAST TYPE OR WHEN I'M WATCHING
THE STUFF.
IF WE HAD BEEN HONEST
INDEPENDENT FACT CHECKER OUT
THERE, THE SPEECHWRITING SHOP
WOULD GET CRUCIFIED FOR THIS ONE
.
>> TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT I
INHERITED WHEN I CAME INTO
OFFICE.
I COULD GO DOWN THE LIST, SO
PART OF IT IS DEALING WITH THE
THINGS THAT LANDED ON MY PLATE
RIGHT I'M NOT COMPLAINING, IT'S
JUST A REALITY.
TO GET IT DEPENDS ON WHAT THE
MEANING OF THE WORD REALITY IS.
THAT TYPICAL MEMORY CARE
PATIENTS REALITY.
ON PLANET EARTH, WHEN JOE TOOK
OFFICE, WE WERE ALREADY
ADMINISTERING OVER 1.5 MILLION
DOSES A DAY NEARLY 19 BILLION
PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY RECEIVED TH
FIRST DOSE BY THEN.
IN OTHER WORDS, PRESIDENT TRUMP
HANDED BIDEN AN INCREDIBLE
VACCINE ROLLOUT AND ALL BIDEN
HAD TO DO WAS EXECUTED.
ANY VACCINE FAILURES AT THIS
POINT ARE ALL ON JOE.
NOT ONLY IS BIDEN GOING FULL
SHARPTON ON RACE AND LYING ABOU
COVID, HE IS GOING FULL SQUAD
ARE NOT JUST THE RICH, BUT
PRETTY MUCH ANYONE WITH A SMALL
BANK ACCOUNT.
>> IF YOU FILE A W-2 FORM, THE
IRS HAS ACCESS TO YOUR BANK
ACCOUNT.
IN YOUR BANK TELLS YOU HOW MUCH
YOU MADE, WHAT YOU HAVE BEEN
THERE AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO
REHIRE SOME IRS AGENT AND NOT T
DO ANYTHING TO TRY TO MAKE YOU
PEOPLE PAY SOMETHING THEY DON'T
KNOW, JUST SAY HEY, STEP UP,
STEP UP AND PAY LIKE EVERYBODY
ELSE DOES.
I REALLY MEAN THIS, I THINK IT'
JUST ABOUT PAYING YOUR FAIR
SHARE.
>> WHAT A COMPLETE SCAM.
NOW WE KNOW A KEY PART OF HIS
JOE JOB PLAN IS TO GROW THE
NUMBER OF IRS AGENTS.
DOES THAT MEAN REVERENT AL WILL
FINALLY PAY UP?
IT WASN'T A BIG DEAL ONLY
$4.7 MILLION IN BACK TAXES.
FROM THE BORDER TO BOOSTERS TO
BANK SURVEILLANCE, WE SEE THE
BIDEN TEAM GRABBING AT ANY
LEFTIST CAUSE THAT PRESENTS
ITSELF.
A DECLINING PRESIDEN